when you turn on the stove to make a
meal you probably aren't thinking about
climate change but major cities across
the country are passing bans on gas
stoves and other appliances that run on
natural gas because of their Planet
warming emissions it's a big deal
because nearly 187 million Americans use
natural gas in their homes senior
National and environmental correspondent
Ben Tracy tells us why the fight to save
the planet could be coming to a Kitchen
near you
at Darrow's New Orleans Grill in Carson
California you got your fresh catfish
fried you can count on a warm welcome
this is what you've been waiting for all
week a hot fryer and that signature blue
flame burning on the stovetop
we've always used gas all these recipes
are gas related Norwood Clark Jr has
been cooking with gas for decades he's
worried that a growing number of bans on
gas appliances in California could
impact his plans to open a new
restaurant near Los Angeles's football
stadium
this is going to put a major major
wrench in those plans when you change
the cooking style you change the makeup
of the product itself
I can't see any legitimate Chef out
there
turn into electric I don't see it really
I don't see it Ben about 80 local
governments have passed laws requiring
or encouraging new homes and businesses
to use electric rather than Natural Gas
Appliances burning natural gas in these
settings accounts for about 13 percent
of U.S greenhouse gas emissions the
largest component of it is methane which
is 80 times more potent than carbon
dioxide at warming the planet so there's
actually not that much about natural gas
that's natural Leah guccione is with RMI
a colorado-based clean energy
organization
she knows the fight over gas stoves has
become a flash point 20 states have
passed laws prohibiting bans on gas
appliances arguing that by itself
cooking with natural gas in homes
amounts to just 0.1 percent of U.S
greenhouse gas emissions there are going
to be a lot of people who don't like
this they like their gas stove do you
worry about turning some people off to
the larger climate issues that we're
trying to combat as a society for
something that is relatively small I
think that's a valid concern really what
we need to think about is eliminating
all of the fossil gas appliances from
our home so not just the stove but also
our furnaces our water heaters if we
have a gas powered dryer the climate
science is showing us that we have
almost no time to waste
at this Denver home researchers from
Stanford are studying the impacts they
say gas stoves produce Planet warming
pollution equal to half a million gas
powered cars each week
natural gas can also raise levels of
nitrogen dioxide in homes potentially
causing respiratory issues including
asthma when you guys went in there and
turned on the burners how quickly did
that reach a limit that's considered
unhealthy it took about six minutes for
the nitrogen dioxide level to to reach
that EPA threshold these pollutants
really do have negative effects on our
health natural gas is safe it's
affordable it's clean the Natural Gas
Association disagrees with Stanford's
findings it says it's working to reduce
emissions and that most consumers simply
can't afford thousands of dollars to
switch to Electric appliances so at the
end of the day this is a very expensive
proposition for very little
environmental gain what can I get for
you there Norwood Clark Jr says he cares
about climate change but if he's ever
forced to replace his gas stove I'll
shut it down
because I'm not going to compromise the
flavor you close your business I'll
close it down
really I really would
and that's why the debate over those
little blue flames is so hot that
chicken is amazing for CBS mornings I'm
Ben Tracy in Los Angeles
he sounded pretty serious guys he said
he would close it out now you all know I
don't cook but chefs have told me that
it you can cook better with gas I do not
know sometimes it's something to think
about that is required for certain
dishes is best with gas that's what I've
heard we are messing up I care more
about the planet I have to say